is tonight to safety on the roads good
evening thanks for joining us I'm Denise
Valdez in fact so far this year more
than 120 people have died in crashes in
Metro's jurisdiction now the Spring
Valley area command has seen the most
crashes overall and many are hoping for
change Sasha Loftus joins us now live
near South Durango and the 215 with more
tonight Sasha
this new intersection was just put into
this new signal rather was just put in
today as everyone in this area gets
ready for Durango hotel and casino to
open now those who live nearby also hope
it'll help with the issue of increases
of crashes nearby
I think people just need to
start listening to their conscious
unconscience when they when they drive
years after she suddenly lost her son
Susan Smith is pushing for safer roads
it's so easy to prevent these things
um so that's why I don't understand why
they keep happening twelve-year-old
Johnny Smith was hit and killed by a car
here at RP and Fort Apache in 2019 and
crashes just keep happening in the
southwest Valley Metro Spring Valley
area command has reported more than 2
200 collisions so far this year nearly
twice as many as any other area in the
valley when you have a combination of
everything
it could just be deadly officials
unveiled a new traffic signal at Durango
and mall near the 215 Thursday as
traffic increases
retired Nevada State Police Captain
Scott Martin says while improvements
like this can help safer roads really
come down to individual choices speed is
the number one cause of accidents and
and of course driver and attention is
huge its speed we saw firsthand clocking
cars with a radar gun here in a spot
near where Johnny died I'll wake up
motorcycles I I'm surprised people don't
hit the wall more a trend Susan hopes to
change while honoring the child she's
forced to live without
Clark County officials say this
intersection sees about 55 000 cars a
day now as we get closer to the opening
of Durango hotel and casino right here
next year they say they will also be
expanding Madura Avenue right behind me
reporting live in the southwest Valley
tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now